[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live what cognito
here i love podcastsgamer.net
and who is this part gentleman we have
in the realm of facts yesterday hi yeah
my name is cleveland mosher um i'm
studio artist at dread xp so i do a lot
of the art for a number of our games uh
including my friendly neighborhood let's
get into bar friendly this looks
absolutely hilarious i need to know more
let's go let's get right into it yeah so
my friendly neighborhood essentially is
like resident evil but with puppets
right
and um so essentially uh the studio um
which is the my friendly network uh for
years was running uh wonderful
children's content with all of the
living puppets at their studio but after
years they had to close down so now that
the network has been abandoned for years
and the signal is suddenly turned back
on but now they're broadcasting not so
friendly content
so it's your job as a handyman to go and
repair the sick oh they said they're
handyman to go back yeah so you're the
handyman have to go through this whole
like network of terrifying mod you know
like uh puppets but you know the puppets
they're not that scary they just want to
hug
[Music]
that's right let's go let's check it out
right now so let's get in here so this
is start at the beginning of the game
it's a little bit further in so at this
point you've already had to deal with
all sorts of stuff outside
all right let's do normal right now
so this is in the basement
all right
all right so first off uh we have our
really cool pistol it's called the
rolodexer oh that's right so the idea
behind it is it's a lot like an old
school rolodex where you had all your
iphones
well the cartridge is letters and when
you fire them it actually fires letters
of the alphabet it's so good right
this is ricky he's one of the first
puppets um he's a little sock puppet
buddy
oh yeah
um i mean i actually made a sock club
but i don't have it with me today i've
actually made a version of them
guys and everything i know one favorite
stock market
i want to shout out
i love
now if you want to play the demo on your
own time or whatever you can hear the
rest of this dialogue but also let's
just get him out of here for now yeah
all right let's go ahead and grab some
ammo some duct tape as well i'll show
you what the duct tape does in a moment
make sure we go this way now let's go
over through here
so
i don't know if you can see like what
letter is up next also it's so much fun
that lights
wow look at up light source thing really
impressive looking yeah man like the
textures and all the lighting is so well
made
yeah john semanski did such an
incredible job
his brother evan as well
i don't know what is going on with your
game over here
aggressively friendly junebug got me oh
dude
so every time it's so gratifying
um yeah i had the pleasure of doing a qa
on this uh the demo for this and it was
just so much fun like i i love playing
again
so one of the things too is there's a
lot of like love and care put into the
game so even early on it's probably
showing up but even down a little things
like posters on the walls there's lots
of bits of lore and other bits of
stories and stuff um i actually did a
lot of these signs
the world is very cool
and it's been so much fun too i love all
the different types of art like the lore
and the glorious it's a really rich
thing
that definitely you can sense that one
of those that would be inspecting like
getting clues or like putting them on
like items and
so a little bit of all of it so i'm
going to show you our inventory system
too
so you actually pull up a suitcase
um and uh you can like move things
around in it and stuff you know very
similar to like resident evil mechanics
um uh coins uh the ammo for your gun as
well and duct tape so duct tape
is uh when i leave this room you're
gonna see that the puppets that i shot
down earlier are gonna be back up again
we gotta restrain the puppets we gotta
don't show what you're banning me what's
going on
is that is that safe
you know uh i tried it once seemed all
right
that is not faith what's going on what's
going on over here
so that's norman
he's fine norman's a friend we don't
have to restrain them and normally like
if i get up and cause problems
yeah let's uh
leonard takes a few more hits he's a
little bit bigger
he's gonna take a few more shots to go
down we got it we got it make sure i
reload
you're not moving no let's get leonard
too
stop stop it dad puppet
i'll show you something kind of funny if
we go back into the room we'll see here
that leonard um
and junebug who will actually start
talking
about the genius as well
so
boys dialogue
yeah they start babbling at you
like so what what was some of the things
they would be saying
um oh man you know they they say some
really wild stuff um the voice acting in
this game the whole team has just been
incredible and really fun to work with
um but you know it's a lot of things
like oh if you try eating your hands you
know just to put it in your throat you
know and stuff like that it's like oh
what what's going on there
you know sort of stuff like that it's
really fun one thing that i really
appreciate about the game already is it
does not take itself seriously
yeah i love the lighting in this hallway
we only have one tape left should we use
it um i would say no because i don't
know what else we're going to face
lately that's fine
that's strategizing yeah we gotta share
that resources limited these puppets out
of control
let's see where this takes it let's see
what we're
doing yeah
look at it maybe we turn on the lights
yeah that's the handyman that you played
well let's just double check a little
more extra in our inventory
i got
it's so difficult for me to play games
like this and not search like yeah yeah
everything i have
to have that same whole cd like you get
everything it's like i play the civilian
time it doesn't matter
you know there's all sorts of stuff in
here i love like each of these like
assets dudes they're really lovingly
creative by the developers
savage oh no let's get out of here
do we make it can we make it should we
make it oh he got a game
field he got a gang you got to get a
body you got to get a body
please don't tell me they go through the
door i think we're going to never say
that
let's go
actually chocolate bars do something a
little different they speed you up so
you can run really fast
so one of the fun things is that john
simansky uh the creator of the game um
he gave me like a lot of like freedom to
just have fun with because i grew up
watching like uh you know like jameson
movies and things like that so i'm a
huge fan so jim henson that is funny you
said no
yeah and like you know we were thinking
like oh wouldn't it be fun if like the
the warning signs in the game
are uh like made for kind of the puppets
as well since they're saying caution it
says
i sit down with john like once a week
with the rest of the publishing team and
today and every week i'm just stunned by
like how many new things they're adding
to the game there's all sorts of news
places and stuff
is that really like far enough along to
like to test and to figure out exactly
what the length of the game is to give
you full number on that just yet
but um it's definitely a good really
solid few hours to play for sure
um like uh but yeah there's all sorts of
other locations like there's the grounds
there's like the offices there's the
penthouse there's
the there's several sound stages like
there's actually like the street set and
stuff i've been doing big mac paintings
for those lately that's so much fun
um uh also one of the movies as well has
a sound stage the pirate one
the soundtrack is so good in the same
room
isn't that great
yeah like mega dungeon the guy who does
the the soundtrack for this game just
nailed it like absolutely it sounds so
good right now we're working on doing a
version of the theme that actually has
like a full children's choir and like
all the rest of people yeah
as well it's so much fun
let's see what we have here oh let's
miss some more loot
[Music]
yeah i just love that
glad you did that because
it adds a little bit to the ambiance
the attention
detail and how much you guys have a
passion for the music accompanying the
experience oh thank you yeah music is so
important to games
absolutely
changed
yeah so for the demo we wanted to make
sure that like this was a really good
meaty puzzle you know to get people like
let people really get their hands and
you know take into the game
uh definitely off into the deep end of
this and it's been a few months since i
tried this one
it's food it's gonna get me but i if i
remember correctly i could show you one
more
thing cool thing yeah let's see here oh
let's try out the chocolate though check
it out i think the chocolate that lasts
for like a couple of rooms
so let me see here if we take it now
until while we're at it too oh you can
see i'm already moving faster all right
let's go ahead and use one of these too
get our health back all the way up
that comes back around
[Music]
so it's a lot like the uh the rolodexer
except it fires a lot more letters so
i'd like to the uh yeah the guy who
worked here before and is obviously a
big fan of this let's have a look
cool guys
this is one of the future levels
uh i don't know if we can go there
okay we have puppets
in the reload mechanic we gotta give
this to the zero home but we just don't
have any ammo
i think we have five shots only a
popcorn yeah
first
let's go ahead and
so this is ray he was on the stage
earlier he uh he's part of the uh his
original bit was the fix-it
story so like he's uh he's a handyman
like us
anyway let's let's see what we all want
to see which is uh
all right let's roll
multiple letters let's do it again
so uh right now we're also working on a
grenade
and um a uh as well as a beating
implement of some kind
yeah so there's a few other weapons
you'll be able to get in the game as
well um and again this is just one of
the one of the many levels of the game
really cool man loving the art style
again love of the atmosphere just
really really a unique style game
the whole premise of it is to be
absolutely hilarious isn't it
yeah we're looking at 2023 right look at
it
oh man well uh first and foremost too
this demo um
that join our discord too we're very
friendly
uh dread xp uh if you go to drugstee.com
you should be able to find a link there
right as well we do movie nights and all
sorts of other fun stuff too
you heard it here perfect absolute
pleasure thank you so much
and we're gonna dive deeper into it man
we'll turn it up here first i love
podcasting more cognito here
[Music]
you